[Music]
well the left-wing blogs informed me
yesterday that john oliver had returned
to his hbo show to deliver another epic
smackdown this time destroying
demolishing eviscerating
anti-prostitution laws oliver is uh
quite sure that there is no good reason
for prostitution to be illegal he's even
more sure that it's mostly just a bunch
of repressed puritanical bumpkins who
still support such laws now he begins
this segment by playing some kind of
weird 1950s psa about wet dreams don't
ask me why then he proceeds to list a
bunch of sex positions while the
audience cackles uproariously this is
just great comedy watch this
specifically tonight we're going to talk
about sex work and the concept is pretty
simple let's say you have sex any kind
uh missionary doggy cowgirl cowboy the
eagle the wheelbarrow the wild
chinkatique pony the jerry seinfeld the
pick-me-up that put me down mouth butt
butt mouth mouth mouth butt butt butt
butt mouth butt you know whatever but
then that's it you go home it's fine
right
so you see there why oliver needs the
crutch of a live studio audience
because without the mindless drones
laughing that would have just been a
sex-crazed schizophrenic
randomly shouting a bunch of sexual
terms into the abyss
with the laughing it's still that but at
least the people in the room are
enjoying it i guess
but it sets the stage for what's to come
oliver proceeds to lay out his case for
decriminalizing prostitution everywhere
in the country he has 20 25 minutes to
present the argument in favor of
prostitution but waste most of it
talking about alleged instances of abuse
by the law enforcement officers tasked
with policing the practice so he
mentions for example a report claiming
that officers and sting operations
sometimes have sex with the prostitutes
before arresting them
now we can all agree that if that's
happening it's wrong and horrible and
exploitative
but it has nothing to do with whether
prostitution should be legal or illegal
there are plenty of cases of police
officers mistreating murder suspects
that doesn't mean murder should be legal
so before we talk about
how these laws are enforced and i
personally think they should be enforced
by first and foremost penalizing the
pimps and traffickers themselves before
we can do that we need to figure out if
the laws should exist at all
oliver doesn't really have a lot to say
about that subject even though it's
ostensibly the subject of his episode of
this episode of his show but let's
listen to his case for whatever it may
be worth he starts things off by
drawing what actually is a valid
comparison and one that listeners of
this show have already heard many times
listen to this
very basically sex work is the exchange
of sex for money or goods and in the
united states a complicated patchwork of
local state and federal laws makes that
act illegal everywhere except for a few
counties in nevada and if you think it
were hold on john didn't donald
sutherland and julie christie have sex
for real in don't look now and also get
paid at least scale wouldn't that be
illegal the answer is one yes i also
believe that rumor great reference and
two
that is actually legal because of the
presence of the camera making it an art
film otherwise known as porn and thus
legally covered as part of free speech
so basically consensual sex for money on
camera is legal porn and consensual sex
for money off camera is illegal sex work
makes sense right wrong well exactly
everything about the way we regulate sex
work in this country is confusing and
counterproductive
oh where have i heard that before
i mean you're right john that is in fact
a point that i have made many times and
people on your side of the ideological
divide have mocked me relentlessly for
it i guess i need to say with a british
accent for it to be credible
pornography is prostitution on film
it fits the definition in every sense of
the word it makes no sense for
prostitution to only be legal when
there's a camera filming it
in fact if you could only outlaw one
form
the filmed or unfilmed variety it would
make more sense to outlaw the former
because it has more participants
either way there's no denying the
contradiction in the way that our laws
treat prostitution as opposed to how
they treat pornography
my answer to that contradiction is to
make all of it illegal
his answer is to make it all legal and
um let's let's find out why
but a human history's worth of laws
hasn't changed the fact that one sex
work has always been part of society
appealing to every interest in every
kind of clientele and two sex workers
are not a monolith people from a variety
of backgrounds do it for a variety of
reasons and the fact is our current
system of criminalizing the trade and
driving everyone underground is actually
only making life harder for the most
vulnerable involved and given that sex
workers are and this is true people with
thoughts about their own situation we
thought tonight we'd actually listen to
so here john offers two incredible
insights
one he points out that prostitution has
always been around
and two he observes that uh some of the
people doing this illegal thing would
prefer if it were not illegal
now both of these points may seem rather
obvious and irrelevant but remember that
he dropped an f word in there which
automatically makes his point both
powerful and clever and funny
yes we know that there have been
prostitutes for as long as there's been
human civilization that's why the old
cliche about the world's oldest
profession
but we've also had murder and rape and
child abuse and every other bad human
activity for as long as we've had humans
the fact that people have been doing
something for a long time and will
always do it doesn't automatically mean
that there should be no laws against it
if it did then there shouldn't be laws
against anything because the only things
we need laws against are precisely those
things that human beings tend to do
if nobody did it we wouldn't need to
outlaw it
as for the point that anti-prostitution
laws ignore the perspective of
prostitutes that wouldn't be relevant if
it were true
because again pointing out that the
people doing the illegal thing
don't like that it's illegal is is not
really relevant but it's also not true
at all
because some of the most vocal
anti-prostitution voices in the country
are people who've been rescued from that
life
prostitution is bad it harms people it
harms everybody involved in one way or
another
there's a reason why prostitutes just
like people in the porn industry have
astronomically high rates of substance
abuse suicide
any law that could potentially prevent
people from getting involved in this
activity or deter them from it
or at least any law that fails to
condone it
is good for the prostitutes or potential
prostitutes themselves even if they
don't always have the self-awareness and
foresight to see it that way you know
it's it's pretty common for people who
are stuck in a self-destructive cycle to
defend their self-destructive activity
and to get very angry at anybody who
tries to stop them from doing the
self-destructive thing
but that doesn't really mean anything in
terms of what the law should be
now we'll return to that point in just a
moment but first we'll continue
listening to oliver's argument such as
it is
so far he hasn't really presented any
reason to decriminalize it perhaps he
finally gets to that point here
this story is going to be about the fact
that sex work is inarguably labor it is
a job and people do it for the same
reasons that people do any job as this
advocate explains
sex work is inherently work it's how
people
feed their families is how people put
clothes uh on their backs it's it's you
know how people survive i mean i've been
a sex worker i've been a lawyer i've
served sandwiches at somewhat at subway
i folded clothes at abercrombie all
those are work right it's all work
uh okay
what's your point
yes those are all things you did for
money you folded clothes at abercrombie
you were a prostitute
uh you were a lawyer which would some
would argue is more of a lateral move
all of that is work if by work you
simply mean a task performed for
financial compensation but what does
that prove
are you saying that anything done for
money is automatically good or should
automatically be legal
that's quite an interesting take from
the same people who also tend to be
critics of capitalism
what about child pornographers what
about hired assassins
what about bernie madoff running a ponzi
scheme all of that is work done for
money
if you don't think that all of it should
be legal then you're saying that there
are certain types of jobs
certain types of work
that nobody should be legally allowed to
do in a civilized society even if they
use it to feed their families
the question is whether prostitution
ought to be in that category or not
and that is a question you still have
not really answered and never do but
we'll keep listening
to those who are still uncomfortable
here out of a concern that there are
people who feel economically forced into
sex work i totally agree with you that
is a huge problem but the fact is
our current laws are not addressing that
if you want to do that that's a much
bigger conversation to have because
fundamentally the only way to make sure
that people have a choice in the way
they earn money is to make housing
affordable healthcare accessible and to
not burden marginalized people with
criminal records that lead to a cycle of
joblessness homelessness and desperation
but until such time as we have that
conversation and it does not seem like
something enough people are itching to
have right now
we need to stop pursuing policies that
harass in danger and occasionally
refrigerate sex workers and instead
start listening to what they actually
want because unfortunately if we don't
do that we're just going to carry on
looking like a bunch of
clowns
well speak for yourself john um now he
once again returns to the point that
people who are currently prostitutes do
not want prostitution to be a crime
again i must remind him that most of the
people currently engage in all types of
illegal illegal activity probably would
prefer if the activity was not illegal
it doesn't really help enlighten the
issue at all nor does it do anything to
negate the real reason why prostitution
is illegal almost everywhere and should
remain so
and that is this
prostitution
is human trafficking by definition
it is the human body sold as a good an
object
that's also what distinguishes
prostitution from legitimate forms of
work with legitimate labor you are
providing a good or service in exchange
for money in prostitution
you are the good you are the service
this is also how you differentiate you
know zip recruiter from a slave auction
you're not buying the slaves labor
really you're buying him
the slave himself is the commodity and
so is the prostitute
the prostitute gives herself up to be
used and discarded it is inherently
dehumanizing degrading violent
despair inducing
oliver mentions how poor and vulnerable
people tend to be the ones on street
corners offering to perform oral sex on
strangers which is true but he never
stops to ask himself why
putting the law aside why is it almost
always poor and desperate people who end
up going down this dark road
there are exceptions of course and the
internet version of prostitution
provides many of those exceptions but
the vast majority of the hookers on
street corners are poor desperate drug
addicted girls
that's not going to change by making it
legal
it's not like if you legalize it
suddenly a bunch of middle class
financially stable women are going to
flock to the corner hoping to get their
turn humping a random dude in a car
parked by a dumpster this is something
that only people in dire straits do
because it is debasing humiliating dirty
and shameful
and dangerous
that's not an argument for making it
legal and if you think it is i have to
question not only your common sense but
your basic moral judgment as well
now the prostitute apologist will say
that the prostitutes are acting
consensually but we know that's not true
in a great number of cases many of these
girls are physically forced and coerced
into it and again you're not going to
alleviate those cases by making the
practice legal
pornography is legal and that certainly
hasn't done anything to put a dent in
the child porn business
the effect has gone entirely the other
way
as for prostitutes many did not choose
that life
that's reason enough to keep it illegal
but even the ones who appear to have
chosen it didn't really choose it people
who think they have choices don't become
prostitutes
you'd think this would be obvious to the
left especially as they're the ones who
say that a boss having sex with a
subordinate is automatically a race a
rapist because because the power
dynamics make consent impossible right
that was the me too logic
now if they can apply that principle to
the workplace
where it should not actually be applied
most of the time how can they exempt
prostitution
but however you look at the consent
question the fact remains the
prostitution is human trafficking it is
the buying and selling of human beings
it is exploitation of the most degrading
and dehumanizing kind
whether everybody agrees to the
arrangement or nobody does or some
people do but others don't or whatever
other combination
it still should not be legal
and john oliver is still today
certainly canceled well i hope you
enjoyed that clip from the matt wall
show if you did go ahead and hit that
subscribe button right down there so you
can stay up to date on all of our future
content